maybe we'll get an announcement of space
force command before the election's over
being in florida we'll see
but i can tell you of all the presidents
we've had in my lifetime as someone who
grew up here
we've never had a president who's done
more for the state of florida
than president donald trump
so my questions for you are you gonna do
all you can to storm the polls between
now and tuesday
to make your voice heard
are you gonna bring your friends your
family and your neighbors and everyone
you know to make sure
they get out and vote
are you going to make sure to support
all of our republican
candidates up and down the ballot
very important finally are you going to
do
all that you can yes vote but also
come to rallies help other people help
canada will you do
everything you can do between now and
tuesday night to re-elect
donald trump the president of the united
states
because i can tell you this
i can tell you this if you look at the
voters that are storming the polls now
we've never had republicans vote early
in person like we're seeing
throughout the state right now we've
never been this close to democrats with
registered republicans
versus democrats much better than we
were just four years ago
and i can tell you if those trends
continue
we're gonna go into election night
you're gonna have all the media
waiting they want to declare bite in the
victory they have all their polls
showing them all these different things
and they're going to be chomping at the
bit to do it and then florida's going to
come in
and they're going to say oh my gosh this
is close we didn't think it was going to
be this close
and the panhandle won't have come in yet
and then the panhandle will come in
and they'll say oh my gosh we have to
call florida for donald trump
and when that happens the die will be
cast
and you will be able to see a victory
sweep the country
and he will be much of the chagrin of
all the elites in our country
he will be re-elected the president
of the united states god bless you guys
thank you so much thank you
but she was more like a movie
she told me
people always
mother always
[Music]
she says
[Music]
twice
[Music]
be careful what
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
she oh
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
is
[Music]
she don't care
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in class
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
saturday
oh
[Music]
it's one of the great american success
stories
a builder who left his mark on skylines
around the world
a businessman with an extraordinary
ability to communicate directly
with the american people a leader who
grew tired of politicians
leading our country down a road to ruin
he didn't do it for money
or power or fame he had all that
he did it because of his love for our
great country
and we will make america great again
donald j
trump beat the odds smashed the
establishment
and won the presidency for the american
people
donald trump has defeated hillary
clinton to become president-elect
hillary clinton has called donald trump
to concede the race it has been a
stunning night it has been a historic
night washington dc the establishment is
terrified and they should be they were
all
all of them wrong making this one of the
greatest upsets in american political
history
immediately upon taking office president
trump
changed things but change threatened the
establishment
and the establishment fought back
democrat obstruction
phony investigations the dishonest media
an incredible 92 percent of stories are
negative
no president has seen anything like it
despite everything
they threw at him president trump
delivered for the american people
and he delivered like never before
building the strongest economy in
american history
seven million new jobs the lowest ever
unemployment for black and hispanic
americans ending the biden era of
lopsided trade deals that sent our
factories overseas
passing the historic taking on
china winning the trade war protecting
and strengthening medicare and social
security
lowering the cost of insulin delivering
the first real drop in drug prices in
50 years restoring our military fixing
the va
bringing our troops home and taking the
world's deadliest terrorists
off the battlefield sulaimani
al-baghdadi isis
brought to justice moving america's
embassy to jerusalem
a new era of strength and solidarity
with our ally
israel negotiating a historic peace deal
between israel and the united arab
emirates
securing our border miles of new border
wall being built
illegal immigration dropped to the
lowest point in a decade
tackling the coronavirus head-on banning
travel from china
mobilizing government business and the
american people to manufacture masks
ventilators and medical supplies and
launching
operation work speed an unprecedented
effort to develop a vaccine
to eradicate the coronavirus from the
face of the earth
in record time president
trump has accomplished more for the
american people in four
years than any other president in
history
and in his second term he will lead
america to even greater heights
training the swamp rebuilding the
economy bringing back
millions of jobs creating 10 million new
jobs
in 10 months new opportunities for all
americans
not just those at the top lowering drug
costs
expanding access to high quality health
care for every american family
defending america's police restoring law
and order to our cities
stopping illegal immigration and
protecting american families
and ending america's reliance on china
once and for all bringing back jobs and
factories
making medicine and products in america
again
president trump will rebuild america's
infrastructure
renew hope and our entrepreneurial
spirit for a new generation
and restore the american dream it won't
be
easy never pretty the swamp will
continue to fight him
every step of the way but under
president trump
our families will thrive our incomes
will rise
our communities will be kept safe our
factories
will flourish our flag will fly high
our country will soar and we will
make america great again
is
[Music]
open your eyes
look up to the skies
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't really matter
[Music]
just kill the man
put a gun against
[Music]
god
[Music]
didn't mean to make you
[Music]
is
[Music]
too lazy
[Music]
goodbye everybody
i've got to go
gotta leave
[Music]
i wish i'd never been bored at all
[Music]
[Music]
i see a little silhouetton
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we will not let you go we'll not let you
go
[Music]
thank you can stop me
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing you ever
[Music]
nothing really matters to me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
somehow i think you've got to slow down
you really don't remember
all the voices in your head
[Music]
if everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
hurry up but you really don't remember
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
that you've been living under
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
for the band
[Music]
music man
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
jesus freaked
out in the stream
and then tickets out for gone
turning back
[Music]
she just laughs
full of art is not that
[Music]
in their auditorium
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
the way she knows
[Music]
i feel sorry lying here
with know i'm near only you
and you can't hear me
when i say softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
lay me
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
do
[Music]
seems to score the band
[Music]
you marry a music man
[Music]
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dance in my head
[Music]
and you can hear me
when i say softly
slowly
[Music]
all the clothes are tiny
count the headlights on the highway
leave a comment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
him
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
trying to
say goodbye
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
please please please
please
[Music]
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
got me wrong
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
[Music]
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
[Music]
i've made a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
of the world
[Music]
i've taken my bout
[Music]
but it's been no bed of
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
we are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
he's
hey
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states
donald j trump and the first lady
melania trump
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
[Music]
[Music]
i know
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello florida
[Applause]
it is wonderful to be here in our home
state
thank you for taking the time to be here
and for supporting the administration
we love you too for those
of you who are still deciding who to
vote for on tuesday
i hope that what i have to say will
prove
to you that a vote for president trump
is a vote for a better america
in a time when hate negativity
and fear are the messages the media
streams
into our homes and the large tech
companies
are protecting political censorship we
need to remember
what is really important my husband's
administration
is focused on the future
the health and safety of the american
people
the education and well-being of our
children
the safety and security of our streets
and communities
[Applause]
[Music]
and the protection of our fundamental
family values
under donald's leadership we have
blocked out the noise and focused on you
the american people
[Applause]
under my husband's leadership our nation
is respected again our borders
are safer
[Music]
we have won worse and we have stayed out
of new conflicts
we have made historic peace deals in the
middle east
[Applause]
we didn't just talk about it we moved
our embassy to jerusalem
[Applause]
the president stand with our friend
israel
more than any other president before
our allies are now doing their fair
share globally
our economy sword and unemployment
shrank our military is stronger than
ever
opportunities for women and specially
working mothers
expanded in our workforce
healthcare for every citizen remains a
priority for him
and as you have seen over these past
years
he won't stop until he gets it done
we have a law and order president
[Music]
[Applause]
donald tries to protect and support
all our people
[Applause]
he also fully supports our men and women
in uniform
while others are calling to defund them
we have faith in our judges and our
legal system
to rule justly we respect
our heritage and we condem all
hate
[Applause]
we should always learn from our past
and it is more important than ever that
we never forget it
under this president our american values
and ideals are protected cherished
and upheld we have
had three incredible years of making
america great again
[Music]
in early 2020 our
[Music]
in early 2020 our nation began feeling
the effects of a global pandemic a virus
that invaded
our nation and no one really understood
now because of our amazing medical
capabilities
and resources we are in the process of
developing
powerful therapeutics and vaccine
[Music]
[Applause]
a vaccine is not a partisan issue
if you are not supporting the safe
production of a vaccine
you're not supporting the health and
safety of the american people
[Applause]
there is no room to play politics on
this topic
in the midst of pandemic i want to take
this moment to say thank you to the many
amazing frontline workers who are with
us today
thank you for all that you're doing
you keep our most vulnerable citizens
safe
our administration fully supports you
and will continue to work tirelessly
to ensure that you are equipped with all
the medical supplies you need
this
[Music]
this administration also continue
working to develop
safer procedures and practices
so the children can get back in the
classroom
so that businesses can continue the
opening and people can start earning an
income again
this president and his team are focused
on not only destroying the virus and
building back the economy
they're focused on the creating ways for
people to safely stop
isolating and start gathering with
friends again
on a safe distances
this is about mental health as much as
it is
cyclical
[Music]
we are a country of hope
not a country of fear or weakness
[Music]
[Applause]
and we have a leader who shows us that
every single day
president trump chooses to move this
country forward
this country deserves a president with
proven results
not empty words and promises
on tuesday the direction of our country
will take
is in your own your own hands
i ask that you join us in continuing to
put america first
[Applause]
together we will overcome this pandemic
and continue building the brightest
future for generations to come
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you god bless you all god bless
your families
it is now my pleasure to welcome the
president of united states
donald j trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow thank you very much that was a
little bit of a surprise
that was a surprise thank you melania
good job they love our first lady they
love our friends
always
and america is blessed to have you thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm thrilled to be here in
my our home state
florida
i love this state and i love the people
of this day
and five days from now we are going to
win florida we are going to win
four more years
and we're going on to win a record share
of the
hispanic american vote you see what's
happening
oh they're very concerned back there the
fake news they are so concerned
melania you don't know too much about
them you've seen enough
but they are very unhappy you know
what's happening don't you see what's
happening
we've led florida every single day
what's going on this is a terrible thing
for them
actually it's a good thing for them they
just don't know it
they haven't quite figured that out yet
now we're doing incredibly in florida
we're doing incredibly all over
and this isn't based on polls this is
based on facts
this is based on votes that are coming
in
but you have to get out and vote we are
creating the greatest
red wave in the history
oh it's been amazing we'll talk about it
a little while i want to get some of the
little introductions
and introductory things out but we have
to talk about the uh
what's going on in our country with the
big tech you know the power of big tech
they're incredible
they're incredible no no no i heard
about the power for a long time the
power of big tech
i heard about it four years ago sir big
tech is against you they're tremendously
powerful
you can't beat them then we had the
election we won i said oh
how did that happen and the fake news
media 94
of the stories about us are negative
think of it
think of it 64 of the stories about
sleepy joe are positive how the hell do
you have a positive story about this
how do you have a positive story about
them
this election is a choice between my
plan to deliver
historics and you know what this is
going to be right
historic this is historic prosperity
another major tax cut to go along with
the biggest tax cut in the history of
our country
and record job growth and joe biden's
plan is to deliver
punishing lockdown she's going to lock
you down
and florida's all opened up you have a
great governor did he speak too long
today or not no
no i watched him on the plane i said oh
look there's ron you know they have the
little thing
in the box i said oh look there's ron
he's speaking
he looked like he was up there a long
time
[Music]
no she said yes
uh he's a great governor you have a
great governor he's a great guy
they want to give you massive tax hikes
the first time that i've ever seen i've
been with politics all my life
essentially
only doing this for a few years on this
side of it
but we've done well haven't we when you
think
a senator came into my office said sir
an older guy nice guy pro total pro
so i've been in nine races and i've won
seven of them sir and i'm a united
states senator i said senator i've been
one rank
and i've won one now we want to win two
but i wouldn't
but it was the presidency we took them
all by surprise didn't we we took them
by surprise
they're still trying to recover and you
will have a crippling
depression the likes of which you've
never seen
if sleepy joe becomes your president
and your 401ks throw them out the window
because you know what's gonna happen
and you know our stock market has a big
headwind the headwind is if he wins and
we are doing great do you see the number
today 33.1
gdp the biggest in the history of our
country
by almost triple right almost triple
now it's uh very much bigger than any
gdp
we've ever had you have to go back to
the 1950s and then it's less than half
this is the greatest number 33.1 percent
if you ask me two weeks ago i would have
said i'll take 12
12 would have been very nice nobody ever
heard of 12 percent
33.1 and let me tell you what they're
going to do
i never even thought of this one they
won't even talk about it this is the
biggest event in business in 50 years
nobody's ever seen a number like this
this is bigger than any nation no nation
has a number like that
other nations right now they're look we
were compared to europe
germany is doing so well france is doing
so well everyone's doing so well no
they're not doing well
and you take a look at what's going on
and we want the best for them we're on
their team
we want to work with them and everything
else but they're not doing well
they're spiking up big they're shutting
down they're locking down i disagree
with that because we're never going to
lock down again
we locked down we understood the disease
and now we're open for business and
that's what it is
and that's what it is this explosive
economic growth
is four times greater than what the
experts expected they expected a number
that would be like
7 8 but here's what's going to happen
you're going to go back home you're
going to say that was incredible melania
was unbelievable
the governor the governor was incredible
he
i've never heard anybody speak like that
trump was okay
but we have no choice we have to vote
for trump because it's between
trump and sleepy joe and anybody beat
sleepy joe
i could take a couple of these guys
they're friends of mine
they're not good people they're better
than joe i will tell you
now do you believe what i'm running
against
i'm running against the worst candidate
in the history of presidential politics
i don't care wouldn't lose a draw
this is the worst candidate in the
history he shouldn't be there
because pocahontas kept going instead of
getting out then it would have been
against bernie which
would have been fine too you know what
you would have had a more energetic base
if we had bernie that's one thing
because i don't know if they have a base
here's what's happened he goes for a
speech
they're showing you thousands and thou
look as far as
all the way back to that building as far
as the eye can see
[Applause]
and biden is leaving his basement today
he took the lid off you know what he
does
he takes the lid off runs to the closest
part of delaware like if you can get a
little piece of pennsylvania
people in pennsylvania are wise to him
they know all about his no fracking no
fracking no fracking then he gets to
pennsylvania he learns
it's a million jobs and by the way
pennsylvania
they give us that you can fire up your
factories they give us the energy
and it's inexpensive energy so it goes
to pennsylvania
all of a sudden he changes yes so i have
nothing against fracking
and the press doesn't call him out on it
right and they don't call him out
on where's hunter they don't call about
where's hunter
where is hunter is hunter in the crowd
they don't call him out
they don't call them out on wares
[Applause]
hunters
ah it's crazy that's crazy you know some
people said i get a call from all the
experts right
guys that ran for president six seven
eight times
never got past the first round but
they're calling me up sir you shouldn't
be speaking about archer
you shouldn't be saying bad things about
bike because nobody cares i disagree
you know maybe that's why i'm here and
they're not but
they say they say talk about your
economic success
talk about 33.1 the greatest in history
now look if i do
i mean how many times can i say it i'll
say it five or six times during the
speech 33.1
but you look at that and you look at
tucker carlson what he did the other
night
great and followed up by sean and
followed up by
laura and the next day nothing
at all right nothing nothing in the new
york times
the fake new york times hey how about
anonymous did we see anonymous a low
staffer
anonymous turned out to be a guy i'm
trying to figure out
i don't know who the hell this guy is so
the new york times said
a senior white house official nobody
knew who he was
this was a look we are in big trouble
with the press
they are truly the enemy of the people
they are the enemy of the people
so this guy this guy he goes out
this low life well i never i never saw
him i think he has a picture of me
standing there
like i do with thousands of people this
lowlife goes out and he writes a book by
the way when he left he had nothing but
praise for the trump oh it's incredible
incredible
then somebody gets him at the new york
times the fake new york times
and all of a sudden he becomes nasty and
he writes and they say
a top white house official well he was a
staffer
low had nothing to do with the white
house he had nothing to do
and he goes in and you know what there
should be major
criminal liability for some scum like
this
and you know for a year everybody walks
into my office secretary of state
pompeo i could name every one of them
all good people i'm looking at them and
saying i wonder if that could be the one
you and it turns out to be this low life
that nobody knows who the hell he is he
had nothing to do with us
i don't think i ever met him and i might
have met him i think somebody said
he has a picture of me standing
someplace
this is a disgrace to our country it
shouldn't happen
and he should be prosecuted are you
listening to me back in washington
he should be prosecuted
[Applause]
along with the new york times because it
was a story made up it was fake
news made up by the new york times and
you know who he works for
now cnn he works for cnn right there
[Applause]
see the camera right there with the
light that just went off
see that honey that red light just went
off
fake news cnn and anderson cooper
and anderson cooper asked him are you
anonymous
and he lied to him he said no
essentially said no i'm not
and he works for cnn i would think cnn
would be firing him about but this is a
real low life
you know who else he works for google he
works for google
i think google should fire him very
quickly because bad things are going to
happen to him but think of what he does
to our government
right it's like a horrible treasonous
horrible thing
that you can do this and you can get
away with it
weekly jobless claims this is boring but
it's really good
just hit a seven month low in other
words from the beginning of the pandemic
seven months ago
[Music]
no we're going to have next year the
best year we've ever had economically
and it's true biden is holding back the
stock market because you know it's an
election crazy things could happen maybe
100
of the people in florida decide not to
vote you know you never know
but we have a headwind so it's gone down
a little bit over the last few days
because you know you're coming close
and it could be we're going to win this
election so big you watch
we're going to win it and that's the
only reason the market's going down
the market's going down because if he
gets in
seriously you're going to have one of
the worst depressions we've ever had
you're going to have and john roberts
from fox's back there and i think he
agrees
and john roberts is very unhappy because
he doesn't want his 401k
to go down the tubes now john's treated
us very fairly not perfect he's not
perfect i will say
but he's been overall pretty good he's
pretty good
so cnn google we've got to do something
about all of it new york times is fake
it's fake they write so many fake
stories
thanks to our policies america is
experiencing the fastest
and biggest recovery we're having the
best recovery
anywhere in the world no other country
small or large is recovering like us
think about it in the past five months
we've created a record 11.4 million
american jobs
the fastest job growth in the history of
our country
our job growth has been 23 times faster
than the first five months under obama
biden
recovery which was by the way the worst
recovery since the great depression you
do know that right
and just you know because all all
biden does is talks about covent right
he doesn't call it the china virus you
know why
because china hasn't paid off he can't
use that term
you know they gave his son one and a
half billion to manage he makes millions
of dollars a year i assume right
the smartest guys on wall street said no
sir that could not have happened we
can't get it
now he got he took him about what 10
minutes he walked in he walked out with
one and a half billion
hey maybe he's not so stupid after all
right
that's the only thing i thought he was
so dumb maybe he's not as dumb as we
think
he can't look he cannot take on china
i didn't say anything are you
the problem is biden is totally the
biggest story
no the second biggest story the worst
was when they spied on my campaign and
they got caught
that's the biggest political corruption
story
in the history of our country but this
could very well be second
and we have what's called the laptop
from hell
the laptop from now from what i've
understood
you only have seen a tiny portion of it
but you know what the press is now doing
they're blaming
russia it's russia did it
russia is the one that created the
laptop
and russia brought it into that little
shop to have it fixed
russia
i think russia's looking at us and
saying those people are stone cold
craziness
now it was russia's fault they said it
loud and clear it was russia russia
russia
aren't we tired of this crap i saw a
ship
i saw a shift the other day two days ago
watermelon
he looks like a watermelon head
remember he lied in the halls of
congress he read
my conversation with the president of
ukraine
but it wasn't my conversation hey how
great do we
love those people that took down the
language professional military paper
word for word for word if i didn't have
it would have been
my word against shifty shift right
eight times he said quid pro quo think
of what that means
eight times you've asked for the same
thing the guy in the other after the
third time the guy on the other side
would say
he's got some serious problems i don't
even know him i called him to say
congratulations on becoming president of
ukraine
and for that i got impeached but you
know what we have
we have a lot of great republicans and i
hope you're going to be voting for those
republicans also
great republicans we have one of them
here mark meadows has anyone ever heard
of mark brother
took me three years to get him out of
congress and become chief of staff he's
great
he's here he was one of our great ones
and you know who helped me a lot
honestly in fact i said don't run for
governor ron stay exactly where he was a
congressman you governor right
there he is look at mark he's out there
working with the phone he's got the
phone go
he uses two at one time right but your
governor was another one he stood up
you know he's harvard and yale do you
know that your governor he doesn't talk
about it
he doesn't talk about it
but he would be on television defending
me and fighting for me there was a group
jim jordan did anyone ever hear of jim
jones
jim gordon 128 in one you know jim was
an ncaa wrestling champion one of the
best
one of the best he was a great one he
was a great one and you know
when you win like he won he won
everything when you win like that it's
also right here's muscle
but it's got to be muscle attached to a
lot of brain right you guys know the
athletes know that
but jim was great and uh but ron was ron
was fantastic your governor he asked me
he said
would you support me for governor i said
no not really i'd rather have you stay
right where you are you know
you're doing a good job of defending me
but think of it what we had to do and we
got
190 to nothing in the house think of
that
197th and then we went to the senate
and we had 52 and a half to a half you
know who the half was but that's okay
that was the guy that sleepy joe biden
he couldn't remember his name remember
he said the guy from
uh the guy from isn't he the governor
from that place uh
utah utah i don't know his name i can't
remember his name who's romney
now sleepy joe's a little bit off let's
face it sleepy joe is shot
and i'm not a fan of his and he's not a
nice guy just you know i feel better if
he was a nice guy i couldn't say these
things
he's not a nice guy now he doesn't
remember whether or not he used to be a
nice guy
he was never considered smart he was a
touchy-feely guy you know those guys
touchy feeling
but not a nice guy not a smart guy
our incredible first lady is sitting
here right now
and she's saying and she's saying to
herself
i wonder if all rallies are like this
now most of them are a little bit
different but that's okay you know why
honey we're in florida
this is like home right
this is home
we say it like it is we say it like it
is we created the greatest economy in
history
and now we are doing it again see all
that hat that beautiful hat
let's make america great again right
we're going to make a new one let's make
america great again again
we did it we did it now we're doing it
again
my first lady wants to do it again under
my leadership
the florida tourism industry and
hospitality industry
will come roaring back very soon it's
ready to happen we're making the turn
we've got the vaccines coming very soon
the fda has worked miracles they had no
choice they had
this would have taken if joe was in
charge you wouldn't have a vaccine for
four years
i was going to say he he was in charge
of the swine flu he calls it
n1h1 it's actually h1n1 i say joe
it's not it's h1 h comes it's easy
because h comes before
n i said joe joe that's what that is
i said just go with swine flu you don't
have to call don't the numbers are too
complicated
three days ago he said i'm a proud
democrat running
for the united states senate and i hope
i have yourself
you can't put the look we can't play
games you know you've seen enough have
you seen enough
this is crazy
but based on the early numbers i've seen
i think you understand
exactly what i'm talking about you know
we have the potential
we have the greatest country in the
world but we have the potential to go to
places that we've never been
in a positive manner we can the
potential of our country
is so incredible and you see it
happening already
you look at germany you look at all of
these countries they're now locked down
they've got a lot of problems you look
at our numbers look at our recovery
fastest recovery
we went down the least economically went
down by far as much as it's painful and
terrible
we went down the least we've done an
incredible job it was projected that we
would lose
2.2 million people
right the projections were 2.2 million
by the way we shouldn't have lost one
person china
should have never let this happen they
should have never
let it escape and we will not forget we
will not forget
biden's agenda will devastate the
hispanic american community
he betrayed hispanic americans for 47
years he's been very bad to the hispanic
americans and what on what is happening
with those poll numbers
i have the highest numbers we are now
according to the polls i'm sure which
are real polls we are now beating the
democrats for the first time ever
with hispanic americans first time
first time ever and i've always loved
them and i think they've always loved me
first time ever first time ever and the
the fakers back there are going
crazy and now biden wants to close your
small businesses and confiscate your gun
second amendment don't worry about it
the second amendment
while letting far left rioters looters
and vandals roam free
look what he's doing in philadelphia
look what what's happening those are
people that
he's supporting he couldn't even come
out against him yesterday they asked him
a question
he said uh what's philadelphia where is
it
he didn't know what state it was in
other than that he's doing a wonderful
job could you imagine
could you imagine losing to this guy
could you imagine
our first lady will have to say darling
i don't know if this is impossible
but you have to be very careful when you
say that you know whenever i say
anything that
even uses the word losing the fake news
said
he is thinking about losing this is a
big story
president trump thinks he's going to
list no i don't
i don't i think you're going to lose and
i think you've lost
all credibility
and our elegant first lady sits and she
says what the hell is happening here
this election is a choice between the
american dream
and a socialist nightmare that's what it
is it's socialism
venezuela i used to say venezuela on
steroids
this is this would be if they got in a
very
very very large version of venezuela and
it can happen
with the green new deal and all these
crazy you know look aoc plus three
i heard she's very insulted that i call
her aoc
i'm not i call her aoc plus three that's
the three characters that
like ilhan omar i'm gonna win minnesota
because of ilhar omar
she tells us how to run our country
she's telling us how to run our country
i don't think so ilhan
omar so we're going to win the state of
minnesota for two reasons her
and the fact that when minneapolis had
their problem they should have called us
sooner but when they called us
how long did it take 25 minutes it was
extinguished
we could have done it the first hour
instead of waiting for a week and a half
but the governors they have to call and
i give the governor credit he eventually
called
you eventually call they should call us
i'll tell you oregon they should call us
in portland oh would i love to go in
with the anarchists
they would last 15 minutes or guys you
know
you got to like hold them back they want
to let us in sir we'd like to go in
i mean on my seat trips sir we'd like to
go into oregon we'll take care of them
i say just calm down just calm down it
wouldn't take them long it would take
them about 15 how long and then we'd
well we'd do things and then eventually
they'd end up going home
about 10 years later back home to mom
and dad where they started in the
basement
antifa you know antifa
so biden called it an idea he said
antifa's just an idea
i said no when you get hit over the head
behind your back with a baseball bat
that's not an idea
that's not an idea but he called didn't
he call the united states he called
the united states an idea too i said no
no it's not an idea
the united states is a great nation
that's what it is
it's not an idea
he called us an idea so he puts us in
the same category as antifa
as long as i am president america will
never
be a socialist country and i say it all
the time
[Applause]
this election will decide whether our
children will be condemned
to the misery of socialism or whether
they will inherit the glorious legacy of
american freedom
this election will decide whether the
biden harris how about her how about
i'll tell you what when our great vice
president
mike pence debated her it was a total
you know the expression if it were a
fight they would have ended it
within two days they were saying the
fake news she did magnificently well
against mike pence no no
no that's what happens you know you do
great great great two days later you
realize
they have a down that you lost now mike
did fantastically he's a great vice
president he works very hard
i'll tell you one thing you know his
kids are in the military and they're
teachers
i guarantee you one thing mike pence has
not made hundreds of millions of dollars
by scamming foreign countries
because that's what they've done they've
made hundreds of millions of dollars
and they can't and nobody wants to talk
about look at that oh are they doing
that on purpose
are they friend or foe
i don't actually felt good i felt water
on my face i said where the hell is that
they may be doing that on purpose let's
find out if they're friend or foe
and if their phone let's take care of
those son of a [ __ ]
look at that
are you okay oh look they're hitting
depressive
that's okay oh there go the cameras
there goes a million dollars worth of
equipment look at that
wow
that's cool actually
and i'll tell the media i have nothing
to do with that but it is sort of like
calling a feeling like a little
that's great
[Music]
you know it's amazing it's amazing and i
say it all the time
because we've liked ronald reagan we've
liked a lot of you know people
mostly their stiffs mostly generally
speaking they don't do the job right
but we've had good ones like ronald
reagan he's the one i think about
but nobody ever chanted first of all
he'd never get a crowd like this he'd
have
two or three hundred people there'd be
in a ballroom that would be that was
like the norm
nobody have you got to see yesterday we
had 35 40 000 people
we were in arizona the day before two
days before we were in pennsylvania we
did three in pennsylvania one bigger
than the next
like this and you know what's common the
love it's all the same the love
is incredible love for our country
it's the love for our country but
there's never been a chance
we love you i'm watching this guy here
he looks like he could take on anybody
in the world he's a big strong guy
i don't think he's ever cried in his
life before and i see him wiping away
tears we love you we love you
this guy he hasn't cried since he was a
baby and probably didn't cry then either
and now he's crying no there has never
been that chant before and i appreciate
it and i'll cry that's why i end it
early
i'll cry except i don't want them to say
your president broke down in tears today
i don't know that's not cool
we don't want we don't want president
xi of china to say gee
i just saw something that surprises me
you know we've taken billions and
billions of dollars out of china
we gave 28 billion to our farmers 28
right out of china
i don't want to have
but then the plague came in right then
the play came in that sort of
everything you know we made a great deal
with china the ink wasn't dry before the
plague came in so it's a whole different
feeling
i will say three weeks ago they ordered
more corn
corn more soy beans more beef
than at any time in the history of this
country
so they obviously think i'm going to win
they obviously think we're going to win
and they want to make us happy but we're
not happy because that should have been
stopped and it's not here all over the
world you see what's going on europe
it's so sad but
you see what's going on 188 countries
all over the world
what china has done to this world
what they've done people come up to me
their clothes and masks and stuff and
this
hello presidential opera i said look
look at this
what china has done to our country what
china
what i may do that you better be careful
what china has done to this country
it's not the first time either
now they're paying their pay but you can
never
pay for 200 000 more lives you can never
pay for that yeah we can
we can make them pay plenty but uh 210
000 lives but it would have been 2
million lives
it's incredible the job that we've done
and that the american people have done
this could have been
2 million lives
they said 2.2 million lives
no they're gonna pay we believe in safe
streets secure
communities and we believe in law and
order not like in
[Applause]
philadelphia
and they can't let that happen they
can't let the looters run wild they
can't do it you can't
either have law and order or you don't
philadelphia can't do what they're doing
and they have good police in
philadelphia they like trump i can tell
you i've got i've been endorsed by every
law enforcement group
new york's finest they endorse me
they've never endorsed a presidential
candidate new york's finest endorsement
it was a great honor
because i grew up with new york's finest
then they are they're incredible people
they're not being allowed to do their
job they've been way he cut back a
billion dollars he took back
and now crime is way up that's not even
the money
they're not being allowed they're
incredible people tough as hell
fair they love our country they're not
being allowed in new york to do our job
between the governor and the mayor
they're being just absolutely and they
want to leave they want to get out they
have plenty of other opportunity
they don't need the danger it's a
dangerous job for all police
but we've been endorsed by new york we
were endorsed by chicago police the
chicago police that's
tough we've been endorsed by
all of your sheriffs you have sheriffs
you have great tough sheriffs i know
many of them but the sheriffs
we had a big ceremony two months ago in
florida ron was there
you were endorsed we got endorsed by the
sheriffs all law enforcement all over
florida
and i asked sleepy joe at the debate i
said joe name one
law enforcement agency just one in the
whole country that endorsed you
he couldn't do it remember then chris
wallace saved him
i had two people i was i was going
against chris wallace and him
chris chris was much tougher actually
chris was tougher than joe
and then i said joe say the words law
and order no
say the words lord order joe sam
and then chris wallace he doesn't have
to do that oh okay chris
now i like chris's father a lot better
than i like him mike wallace the great
mike wallace
you know he did me on 60 minutes it was
a great it was one of the few good
pieces you know he was a tough guy
chris tries to be like him but he
doesn't have what it takes
but mike wallace was a tough tough guy
and he did me in 16 minutes and it was a
great piece
he's never recovered from that
originally but he's he passed away he
was a great guy and a great great
reporter i'll tell you it was a friend
of mine he was a friend of mine
that didn't mean much to chris all we
want is fairness right and i will tell
you
kristen welker i thought she was very
good i really do
i thought she shouldn't have been
because she was far left
her family's a supporter of democrats
her father's a big supporter of
democrats she's a supporter of democrats
should have been very unfair i think she
went out of her way and most people say
she wasn't
wasn't really fair to me but she was
because she always gave me 10 seconds
she said okay
see christian had done that you have 10
seconds 10 seconds to me is like an
eternity
we did a lot of damage in that 10
seconds including to get him to admit
that he doesn't want
oil he doesn't want oil i said texas and
pennsylvania and ohio
are you listening are you listening
and you'll see they were listening on
november 3rd i'm sorry you have to wait
till november
texas pennsylvania ohio oklahoma
north dakota they're all listening and
you're listening because you don't want
your energy prices to go through the
roof right
and michigan was listening because they
want to produce cars and they don't
want to spend all that money on energy
when they're producing all of those
factories that i got to go back to
michigan
and go back to ohio and go back to north
carolina
and start brand new and i'd see prime
minister abby of japan i'd say prime
minister we're tired of taking your
millions of cars
you got to let us have factories well we
can't do that this is a
private decision no no it's not you got
to do it but that is not government i
said
you're a powerful man shinzo he just
retired unfortunately he got
ill but he was a great man he a great
prime minister great guy too
but i said shinzo you have to do it i'm
sorry we're not going to take your cars
you got to make them in this country in
our country
and he said i can't do that but let me
work on it the following morning
five major japanese companies announced
they were coming to america and they did
i called him up i said shinzo i know you
had nothing to do with it but thank you
anyway
no they run it they run it tough over in
japan and china and these other places
tuesday your vote is going to save our
country
most important election we've ever had
we're going to defeat
we are going to defeat the marxists and
the socialists and the rioters and the
flag burners
and the left-wing extremists
we are going to defeat the anarchists
with your support we will fight for
american workers
we will defend our second amendment
don't worry it's very safe
if biden got in your second amendment
has gone so fast you know that
support our police protect our borders
expand school choice so important
ensure more products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa that's what's going to happen
my plan for america will deliver a safe
vaccine
you're going to have it in a few weeks
it's coming very quickly great companies
johnson and johnson
moderna fisa many many companies you're
going to have it
seniors will be first in line to get it
and we will make it available to
everybody free it's not your fault it's
not your fault we're protecting our
seniors
you know if you're a senior and if you
have a heart condition if you have
any kind of a certain type especially
diabetes you're in
big trouble if you get hit by the china
virus big big trouble
so we're going to make that vaccine
we're going to make it free and it's
coming from great great firms
our vaccine will eradicate the virus and
by the way
we have it but whether we have it or not
it's rounding the turn
it's rounding the turn
hey excuse me i'm sure you didn't hear
nobody heard this right
i had it did you know that
i had to get back on the trail i said
this is not good timing
and i got better very quickly first lady
had it
she had it and she got better very
quickly
[Applause]
but i'll tell you who had it also the
doctor went to the first lady and
myself and said baron
has tested positive i said excuse me dr
tested positive for what
he's got covid i said okay then about 12
minutes later i said
doctor doctor how's baron do it he's our
very tall son very tall
has anybody noticed he's slightly tall
he's 14 and i'm saying hello baron
yeah he's great but he's strong but i
said
like 12 minutes later dr sean great
doctor we have great doctors one thing
when you are president you have a lot of
doctors johns hopkins i want to thank
them
walter reed medical center incredible
i mean dr ronnie is now a congressman
from texas how about that
dr ronnie he was before sean and sean is
now oh yeah
sean has been great but sean came up
along with other doctors that baron had
it
about 12 seconds later i said how's
baron doing oh he's okay he shed it's
gone
it was gone like in two minutes i said
hey how come that doesn't happen with me
but i wasn't bad you know it was like a
day
but they gave me a drug remote dear who
the hell knows this was
uh this was a very moderna makes it i'll
tell you who makes it really a great
version
they say eli lilly right rogenaron
and they gave it to me and i woke up the
next morning
and i felt i could have taken the
toughest meanest person in this school
regeneron now i don't know whether or
not it worked
i like to think it had no impact i made
a statement
i said well i'm in no trouble because
i'm young
and i'm in perfect physical shape
i'm a perfect physical specialist
and cnn went crazy he's not
young and he's not imperfect they they
can't take a joke
no but i was better i was better quickly
i was better very quickly
we reduced the fatality rate 85
and now we have the lowest infection
fatality rate anywhere in the world by
far
thanks to our unrelenting efforts
and by the way remdesavir was also
approved
it's supposed to have a great effect i
mean i said give me whatever the hell
you have just give it to me
i wasn't jersey you know the first lady
i don't want anything i don't want she's
very particular right
if i say take an aspirin you'll feel
better no no i don't want to ask her
right she doesn't want that only three
percent
of hospitalizations are right now
china virus so think of that so our
hospitals are ready if
something should happen but that's what
yeah i appreciate that
he said we trust you you can we are
doing the greatest job
of this we except with one thing
publicity
our public relations we're spending too
much time working and not enough time
talking but no matter what you say to
these people it won't make any
difference
and because of the advances in treatment
we pioneered the survival rate
is far over 99 for many groups it's 99.9
[Applause]
and for under 70 it's unbelievably high
for over 70 now it's getting very good
and the drug they gave me that what
we're doing is we're going to make that
available including the
very similar drug it's antibody a very
similar drug from eli lilly
we're going to make that available to
anybody that needs it
should they get the china virus
we're going to make it available free so
if anybody
if anybody's going to need it
if anybody's going to need it joe
biden's plan will delay the vaccine
postpone therapies prolong the pandemic
crush our economy crush our economy we
can't do this
destroy the florida tourism industry
and lock down our entire country we'll
be locked down
under biden's lockdown countless
americans will die from suicide drug
overdoses
deferred medical care abuse
the thing that's happening to families
is the cure remember i said it right the
cure cannot be worse than the problem
itself
[Music]
and you have michigan lockdown you have
pence all democrat governors
you know what's going to happen on
november 4th the day after the election
they're going to open it up they're
doing it for political reasons
because it's so bad for their state and
they think our numbers are going to look
a little worse
california is pretty much locked down
new york's got to open new york is
becoming a very
unsafe ghost now governor open up the
state governor open up the state
you'll see our governor he's going to
make a few words in a couple of minutes
governor from new york is going to be
with us in a little while
you're surprised to see that you'll see
what i mean
there will be no school no graduations
no weddings no thanksgivings no
christmases no fourth of julys
there will be nothing they will allow
you nothing other than that
he's doing a wonderful job europe
imposed crushing lockdowns and today
spain has more than two times more new
cases per capita than the united states
france has over three times and belgium
has over seven times
what we have and i don't want that i
don't want that i don't want
that to happen to them we're helping
them we're sending them thousands and
thousands of ventilators we've become
the ventilator king we're making
thousands of ventilators a month we're
sending them to europe and all over the
world
sending a lot to africa they'll never be
able to get them they'll never be able
to make
we've done an incredible job incredible
job
european lockdowns are not stopping the
virus
but they're creating misery poverty
suffering and death you see the riots in
the street of
italy today in the streets of italy and
the riots they're having in france
the people are tired they can't do it
anymore they can't do it anymore
they're losing their businesses they're
losing their jobs
they go back and the business is closed
for nine months
we can't do it anymore they can't do it
we know the disease we
social distance we do all of the things
that you have to do
if you get close wear a mask always
controversial it's not controversial to
me
you get close you wear a mess social
distance so social distance
you know the bottom line though you're
going to get better you're going to get
better
if i can get better anybody can get
better and i got better
[Applause]
they were so happy they couldn't believe
it that was probably the happiest day
that they've had in years
and then they came out of the hospital
to wave to the people the supporters i
heard
you know these really beautiful rooms
walter reed is incredible the best
the best and rooms the glass heavy glass
panels over the
windows and through all of that heavy
glass brick
and mortar i could hear people screaming
outside a half a mile away
and they were fans of mine with flags
trump flags we love our friends
and they were there for two days they
stayed there all night i mean these
people were incredible and i said to my
incredible secret service people there's
one of them bobby i know i'm not
supposed to say it bobby i love you bob
i said bobby i want to go over and see
him no problem sir
he ripped on that mask he wouldn't even
think about that
i said let's go over and see him bobby
by that time i was in good shape i was
really
i wanted to get out here with you but we
drove in front of those people and we
waved and the people were so happy
it was incredible it was like it was it
was a love fest they were so happy
and i got back and they were saying what
a terrible thing to do
now we got to take care of our people
right we got to stay with our people
including secret service who does an
incredible job thank you
thank you bobby come on come on
thank you bobby thank you secret service
they do a great job
for half a century joe biden has been
outsourcing your jobs
opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood
and treasure in endless foreign wars in
2016 florida voted to fire the depraved
political establishment and you elected
an outsider as your president
who is finally if you don't mind putting
america first that's what we're doing
[Applause]
joe biden is a corrupt politician that
the fake news will not write about they
won't write the story
they won't write it and big tech won't
write it
they won't write the story there's the
outside of the new york post
who just endorsed me by the way thank
you very much it's the fourth largest
paper in the country
got a lot of great endorsements we got
a lot of great jack nicholas you know
jack
he can but he can do everything jack
78 tournaments he wanted he won 18
majors think of that how great that is
that means under pressure you know you
need people like that right people that
can win
under pressure jack but jack gave me a
beautiful endorsement
we got endorsements from a lot of
newspapers all over we got a lot of
endorsements
if biden wins thank you very much
if biden wins china wins when we win
florida wins and america wins it's very
simple
[Applause]
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
[Applause]
and i don't always play by the rules of
washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i have fought for you
harder than any president has ever
fought for the people he loves never
thank you very much there's a lot of
people look where that crowd is it's
that's uh would you like to change
places with some people in the back i
don't think so thank you
thank you that's incredible what a crowd
but they're all like this i tell you no
matter where you go
35 000 45 000 they never mentioned it
you know they never met
but with biden they never mentioned it
either i said show the crowd you know
they have circles
someday i'm going to hire the guy that
does those circles no because it's
really good big thick
nice circles are perfectly done it's the
best part of his campaign the circles
and usually he's got five of them
usually he can't fill them up with
people so he puts the fake news in the
circle
and then they don't ask him questions or
how about the question they asked him
the other day he's walking out with ice
cream
sir what flavor ice cream is it ah
i don't know it's vanilla i think
then they asked him a real question he
ran into the car went back to the
basement
does he have the lid on again today
almost every day how do you put the lid
you know when you do the lid he did it
like five six days recently
that's like 50 of the campaign now they
try and say it's because of kovit
they say the fact that he has nobody at
all show up is because of covet no
it's because nobody shows up
and i think that's the ultimate poll and
based on the numbers that we're getting
uh we're going to do really well on
tuesday
[Music]
[Applause]
who knows it's an election and if we do
win you're going to see a stock market
that goes through the roof your 401ks
are going to go up
by 50 quickly you watch i'm telling you
we know i know all those guys they're
just petrified at the thought
of having massive tax increases
regulation increases
they said we've been through that it
wasn't good that's why they had no
growth that's why they had no recovery
slowest ever remember i said that
slowest since 1929 it's a long time
not only is joe biden corrupt he's unfit
he has no plan to end the epidemic it's
all talk no action like i said at the
debate
91 to 9 you know what that means they
did polls afterwards
91 a respected paul 91
said i have to do it i have to brag you
know why they'll never do it
you know you know do you know the
expression
if you can't get anybody else to do it
do it yourself no 91
to 9 and i'm trying to figure out who
was denied i want to find who these
people were
no it was just ridiculous
ridiculous i think they could have done
better but you know you never know again
this is why you never know his policies
would create a depression and he wants
you to surrender
our country that's what he wants to do
he wants you to surrender our country to
china
to all of these other countries that
have taken total advantage of us
it's really the reason i'm here if it
weren't for the horrible trade deals
with south korea with
our allies you know our allies in many
ways treat us worse
than the enemy the enemy at least we
have our guard up our allies
what they've done to us in terms of
military protection and trade is
disgraceful and when they come out and
they say they like
barack hussein obama much more than they
like trump
that means i'm doing my job you see
you know germany said it the other day
and i have roots in germany
but germany said at the other day they
like barack hussein obama and they
should
because germany is delinquent in their
nato payments very delinquent
they're at a half a level and they're
very rich they can do whatever they want
it's not like they don't have the money
and i call them out i say if you don't
pay we're going to start taking our
troops out
and these people go crazy they go crazy
you watch oh we've already started to do
they'll pay but i just want to play you
a video from
a i was so impressed it's a little bit
you know we only do this for people that
we love we have these very expensive
boards that come along
and this is a largely a woman that
comes from this area her husband happens
to be a
major league baseball player you know
who i'm talking about
he's a handsome guy but she's far more
beautiful
and he's on tampa bay so he's right now
a little depressed i don't know if he's
here or not but if he is i want to talk
to him and say
you did a great job kaylee please come
up here kaylee
and play the video please play the video
joe biden uh censored zero times notably
uh no because we're taking our message
directly to the american people we'll be
making
five rally stops a day five thousand
show up literally we have 25 000 people
uh show up in omaha these are historic
crowds the president takes his message
directly to the american people and
shame on jack dorsey
as the new york post noted today this is
a mob artist this is a shakedown effort
to say delete the hunter biden story the
media won't report on it
social media will censor it delete it or
we will censor the fourth largest
newspaper
in the united states we will block them
from social media
big tech needs to be handled and this
president a second term
will do just that because there needs to
be equity there needs to be a
lack of censorship this is what happens
in north korea not in the united states
of america
yeah look the american people have a
very clear choice when it comes to coven
you can vote on joe biden where you will
be locked down
your schools will be closed your
churches will be closed you won't have
social gatherings
it will be a lockdown versus president
trump
where we are safely reopening this
country americans deserve
jobs they deserve freedom joe biden's
modeling his strategy which is locked
down in the basement
but this president has surged
therapeutics and testing in a vaccine in
record time
we can control this but at the same time
we can open
this country and not lock down like joe
biden will do
that's right it's their livelihood these
are small businesses people who have
worked their entire lives to open
these shops these businesses and then on
top of that you have
30 police officers who are injured on
the first night of the riots one
run run over by a car a chance to stuff
police officers and trunks
a vehicle with explosive devices uh let
me be crystal clear why this is
happening
it's because democrats have enabled the
mob when they attack our police officers
verbally
it ends up that they end up being
attacked physically it's called what jim
comey said
the ferguson effect and we're seeing it
play out yet again so as we have 70 new
infections a day and 29 states
have hit highs is the president's
approach
herd immunity no the president's
approach is
therapeutics which by the way have given
us the lowest case fatality rate in the
world
far lower than europe's right now when
you look across the hospitals in the
united states
the percentage of covid patients and
hospital beds
is 6 it's because this president did
things right you have a 99
survival rate under 70 uh and above 70
because of our therapeutics it's very
close to that because of what this
president did
tearing down bureaucratic barriers
tearing down regulations paving the way
for therapeutics we have done this right
and the europe the united states
comparison tells that story
all right kaylee mcinerney the fact is
every time i've
uh called the president he's quickly
gotten on the line when we asked to get
support for that mercy ship
in southern california he was able to
direct that in real time
what the federal government did working
with
states was a phenomenal accomplishment
we got
2 000 of these vehicle field uh medical
sites that are up almost all operational
now
in the state because of his support
those are the facts
his team has been on it i know a team
when they're on it
and i know a team when they're not on it
his team is on it they've been
responsive
late at night early in the morning we
are working very well with fema region
two
with the army corps of engineers
building four field hospitals
that was a decision the president
himself took and i'm grateful for it
these were just extraordinary efforts
and acts of mobilization and
the federal government stepped up we
needed help and they were there
he said everything that i could have
hoped
for and we had a very long conversation
and every single thing he said they
followed through on
we've got to have double the number of
ventilators that we requested for that
area of the state and in fact
we got them in frankly short order have
we
lost anyone because we didn't have a bed
or we didn't have a ventilator or we
didn't have
health care staff no the president was
extending support for new
swabs so conversation commitment
promise made promise kept
[Music]
now to be fair maybe by
guidance not telling us
because he's forgotten his own plans
watch biden's staff quickly swoop in to
shuffle him along during a quickie
escape the basement trip to pennsylvania
here's the deal
one of the things that that is important
is that
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
barracks
that was terrifying what kind of country
we're going to be four more years of
george uh
georgia he uh gonna find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
[Applause]
i mean who's gonna say it better than
kaylee
so i want to congratulate you
this is our great-looking couple
we almost had the dodgers are they that
good a team they're pretty good right
well you're pretty good too and you're a
great couple and that's a beautiful baby
thank you very much
[Applause]
she's smart she's smart
she picked a major league ball player
you know what it is to get the major
leagues and stuff
you got to be in shape you can't look
like these guys out here
yeah she's great but did anybody say
especially on the pandemic has anybody
said it better than that
that was on this morning on fox fox and
friends
and uh i got to tell you that that group
that threesome
they're great right they're great right
it's a great group in the morning but
she said it on fox and friends
ainsley steve and brian has been really
great right brian it's been great
now they treat us good we're thrilled to
be joined by
your governor who i know is up here
speaking but i'm going to introduce him
a second time because we love him and
he's done a great job and he loves the
people of florida
ron desantis
[Music]
[Applause]
and your lieutenant governor who is a
fantastic woman
and she loves her state jeanette nunes
and we have some warriors you know that
used to work with ron
and without them maybe i wouldn't be
standing here remember 197 to nothing
congressman michael waltz michael
he knows more about where's michael
michael
you get married yet michael please get
married quickly
you'll be so depressed michael
if you don't you're going to be very
very depressed thank you
thank you you better do it quick she's
out of here michael
another great friend of mine and a
warrior gus bilarakis
thank you gus great job
great job great job thank you
thank you and greg
stuby greg thank you very much greg
great job you're doing great
these people are tough we've had some
tell you what
we have some incredible people in
washington attorney general
ashley moody who's doing a phenomenal
job
[Applause]
thank you ashley for everything doing a
fantastic job
florida house speaker chris sprawls
i'm so young
florida gop chair joe gruners joe where
are you joe
where's joe joe how are we doing joe
you'll be out of here so fast if we
don't win this election he'll be gone
we are doing well yep we're gonna win we
don't win ah
our country will have trouble then it's
and vote for the congressman and vote
for
the republicans they want to do what's
right they want to do what's right and
you know it's the right thing to do
we have congressional candidates scott
franklin
and anna paulina luna
i put something out
they have my full endorsement great
going i hear you're both doing very well
win
please doing very well great great
under my administration we're reversing
the damage that joe biden and his group
have done over a 47-year period we're
bringing the
pharmaceutical industry back here and
back to regions of puerto rico they took
it out of puerto rico devastating puerto
rico
joe biden voted to eliminate those jobs
and to send them to china
and we're reversing that and we've been
reversing it now for over two years
and it's moving very rapidly last month
i also announced 13 billion dollars in
disaster relief for puerto rico they got
hit hard
they're in a little path that causes
problems you know that right
a lot of hurricane problems speaking of
hurricanes you have a lot of hurricane
problems too and i'm always there ron am
i always there
ron calls up sir i'd like to speak to
you what is it about another hurricane
yes
how many billion do you need rod
but i'm always there and rick
i'll tell you what rick scott's been
great he's been great
and marco rubio has been great
very strong guys strong leaders good
guys too
really good guys marco and rick you have
great people here
great leadership under my leadership we
achieved the most secure border in
united states history
and we have now built over 400 miles of
war
of wall
and we'll have it finished very shortly
it'll be finished very soon you don't
hear about it anymore
you used to hear when they didn't think
i'd be able to pull it off and that was
a tough one they were
willing to close up the country over the
wall so i had a party totally strong
party
bad politics but strong party bad policy
but they didn't want a wall but i made a
really terrible mistake
i should have said instead of we will
build a wall i should have said
we will not build a war they would have
given me all the money they would have
said
they would have said we demanded you
build it immediately
but then they said walls don't work and
i said no walls work and wheels work
those are the two things that
those are the two things that work
everything else gets obsolete
in about 15 minutes after it's
discovered
biden wants to terminate our travel bans
and surge refugees
from the most dangerous places in the
world he will
open the floodgates to radical islamic
terrorism
and you saw what happened three days ago
the beheading
in france and today it happened again
and we give our warmest regards to
president macron a friend of ours a
friend of mine a friend of the first
lady the great
two great people first lady of france is
a great woman
under the biden planned the horrifying
attacks in france
we'll come to our cities and our towns
and i don't want to speak too loudly
about this
and i knock on wood this is real wood
you know
this is real wood i can tell anything
having to do with the white house and
the president's real wood
somewhere oh yeah here let me knock on
this piece that's definitely
but you know what look at what's
happened long time right i don't want to
say a long time
and you know the first call i get after
we win the first call i get will be from
iran
they're going to want to make a deal
because their country has been
devastated
they have been unable to give money to
terrorist organizations that they've
given routinely for years
their gdp is down 27 this year which is
the highest anybody's ever seen of any
country
one year think of it we're up 33.1 and
they're down
27. and they're going to want to make a
deal and we want to make a deal if we
can we want them to be a great country
but they cannot have a nuclear weapon
they cannot have a nuclear weapon
and we're going to help them we're going
to help them we're going to go with them
and help them and do whatever we have to
do
under my leadership we're keeping the
terrorists
extremists and violent criminals the
hell out of our country that's okay
if that's okay with you some of you
might object
because you have that nice liberal point
of view but if that's okay with you
we'll keep them the hell out
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s
military including 11.2
million think of this 11.2 million
dollars
right here mcdill air force base
has anybody heard of mcgill has anybody
in the audience
mr congressman you're the one that got
it
you're the one that got it included
waltz
and we also passed veterans choice and
veterans accountability they all said it
was impossible
they said it was impossible
and we took 100 of the isis caliphate
destroyed it
and we killed the leader of isis
al-baghdadi who are there looking for
for
17 years al-baghdadi is dead
and then we took out the world's number
one terrorist by far
the worst in 50 years kasim
salamani is dead
killed many of our soldiers he killed
many soldiers from many countries most
feared man in the middle east
he's gone i withdrew from the last
administration's horrible
iran nuclear deal i recognized the
capital of israel and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem
[Applause]
and got the building built for tiny
fraction you know that story right tiny
fraction
i called up our great ambassador david
friedman i said david
let's see if we can get it open they
wanted to spend two billion dollars to
build an embassy jubilee and it would
have never happened
i said david go around do we have any
land that we own with the government we
own everything right
even in other countries see what we have
he calls me back the following day he
says sir
we own a great piece much better than
the piece they were going to buy
we didn't buy it because i didn't like
it i didn't like the location does that
make sense because i'm in the real
estate i didn't like location
location's very important i said see
what we have he said sir we have a piece
that's much bigger it's in a much better
location
and it has a building now remember we're
gonna spend between a billion and two
billion dollars
i said well what's the building he said
the building is a building that's
basically unoccupied it's pretty big
we could fix it up i said how much he
said let me get back to you gets back to
me two days later
sir i think we can do it for 390 000
right right you understand that mr
congress
so i said you know it's the first time
i've ever done this i said david that
doesn't sound good it sounds too cheap
make it a little more make it 500
and we did we did it for 500 000. and
you know it's jerusalem
and a friend of mine ron barron he's so
proud of a wall opposite the elephant
every time i walk in he shows me
jerusalem stone i go crazy
ron i don't care i said david
you're in jerusalem it's very expensive
in new york can you get jerusalem stone
i said yes we can we have it we can buy
it for nothing
i said good make the building out of
jerusalem stone
so we made it out of jerusalem stone we
had it opened four months later for five
hundred thousand dollars
that means because you know what not
only would it have cost more than two
billion dollars
you wouldn't have that building built
for 25 years
so we got we did something a little
different we got something done for a
tiny
tiny
fraction of what it was supposed to cost
and we had it open in
three and a half four months and it's
now our embassy it's a great embassy
and it's recognized jerusalem is the
capital of israel
sort of a great story and i also
recognize
israeli sovereignty over the golan
heights they've been working on that for
52 years we got it done in two hours
and it's not easy and every president
wanted to do those two things for many
many decades but they
they could and i understand why they
could a lot of pressure a lot of
pressure against
and instead of never ending wars in the
middle east we're forging peace deals
all over the place you see
no blood in the sand no blood in the
sand no cost
biden and obama made a pathetic
one-sided deal
with the castro dictatorship my opponent
stands with socialists and communists i
stand with the proud people of cuba
and nicaragua and venezuela in their
righteous struggle
for freedom and we're winning we're
winning it it's
going to be easy the last
administration also negotiated the
terrible
obama biden santos deal
with colombian drug cartels surrendering
to the narco terrorists you know what
that means that means drugs our first
lady sits on
our commission she chairs the commission
of drugs and
on drugs in america and how to get rid
of it
it's a blue ribbon commission right
and we're down 19 we had a little
setback with the
recent problem with with the china virus
but it's
getting back under control but she's
taking it down 19 she and the commission
have taken it down 19
and she doesn't want it mentioned she
doesn't want to talk about
it she doesn't want to talk about it so
if it were me
sitting in her position i'd be holding
in this conference
i have done an incredible job
now i'm only i'm only kidding i'm only
kelly
but she has done an incredible job thank
you honey
[Applause]
under my stacking
thank you very much under my
administration
we worked with colombian officials to
seize or disrupt
227 tons
of poisonous narcotics since april alone
the fact is i've done more in 47 months
and sleepy joe biden has done in 47
years it's true
it's true no administration
in the first three and a half years has
done what this administration's done
we've rebuilt our military
we've done the biggest tax cut in
history biggest regulation cut in
history
what we've done is incredible even
environmentally i tell you what
we're not going to go over a list would
be here all day but no administration
and you know the fake news doesn't even
call me on it
they don't even if i'm usually if you
make a statement they think it's like
one percent off it's like a headline the
next step
in the coming weeks we will distribute a
vaccine defeat the virus and complete
the great american comeback we're in the
process
a vote for republicans like these people
right down here
is a vote for the great american dream
that's what it is
i remember abraham lincoln the great the
legendary
abraham lincoln was a republican would
you please remember that nobody knows
that
they know it now because i like to say
it over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower
of the world and we will end our
reliance on china once and for all it's
already so
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will defend religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment will be defended
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and i told you we spent two and
a half
trillion with a t trillion dollars
trillion on our military we have the
finest rockets the finest missiles the
finest jets f-35s
we have the finest tanks and submarines
and ships
all made in the usa and our nuclear
stockpile we are
in a position like no other country in
the world we're the envy of every
country russia
china north korea no country in the
world has
what we have and just a lot of religious
people in this audience
pray to god that we never have to use it
and it's more likely that we won't have
to use it
now that we have it but just hope that
we never have to use it
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency lower drug prices
even more
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman in the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars it's
already happening now
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our school
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history and
always respect our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who's standing
up for america and standing up
for the great people of florida
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your boss pull them
out of the chair
come on boy and you got to get out and
vote there's never been an election more
important
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the rest of the swamp we've
done a lot of it
from pensacola to miami from orlando to
jacksonville
and from tallahassee to right here in
tampa
we inherit the legacy of thought oh you
know what right
we inherit the incredible legacy of
florida patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears for
this beloved
nation we stand on the shoulders of
american heroes who crossed the oceans
blazed the trails settled the continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads dug out the panama canal
raised up the great skyscrapers won
two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and from right here in this beautiful
state
landed our brave american astronauts on
the face of the moon you've done a lot
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power
to you the american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning winning
we're winning we are winning again we
are winning again
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of florida
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you florida get out
and vote thank you
[Music]
young man there's no need to feel down i
said
a young man pick yourself off the ground
i said young
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
to enjoy
you can have a good meal you can do
whatever
[Music]
but you've got to know
mca i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
they
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone came up to me and said
[Music]
it's fun
[Music]
[Music]
you can hang out with
[Music]
[Music]
pick yourself up
[Music]
young man
[Music]
i was down
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
smile
you're marrying music man
[Music]
ballerina you must have seen us
[Music]
always with me
[Music]
jesus reached
out in the street
and then tickets are gone
turning back
[Music]
shot on my hand
[Music]
she sings the song
[Music]
the word she knows
[Music]
[Music]
softly
slowly
[Music]
count
[Music]
[Music]
on the
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby
you